[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
everyone and welcome to the arguments
podcast first look of a game called
hades
by supergiant games now
what i thought this game was was a
little bit of a sleeper for me now
i never originally played it back when
it originally came out
i only recently got into playing it
because of it
coming out of its uh early access
now when i started playing it i thought
to myself
oh man it's another type of roguelike
that's a top down
what what am i going to do here am i
going to like it am i not going to like
it
oh man i don't know and then i started
playing it and
it's so good now it's a little bit
different than
the normal you know type of roguelike
game
where you have that uh that
type of ability to get your gear over
and over and over again
so what ends up happening when you're
playing hades is you're gonna be ending
up going through the game as playing as
one of
hades's sons and he is trying to escape
the underworld
now throughout this time what you're
going to end up doing is you're going to
end up
getting keys and getting gear to make
your character stronger to allow you to
then end up trying to
leave the underworld now the reason why
this is
super interesting is because
you're gonna die a lot and you're gonna
die often
now i played this for about
two and a half three hours and i got
instantly hooked and i want to play more
of it
and i want to get better at it now the
game came comes up with you being able
to get
special abilities from people that are
other gods
like zeus aphrodite dionysus
you're going to get all these different
people to be coming and helping you out
now what's really really interesting is
every time
you end up getting a power up you have
to make a decision on what you're going
to do with that powerup if you're going
to end up using it
to increase your main weapon if you're
going to use it to increase your ranged
weapon
or your dash or what you're going to end
up doing or you're going to have you
know
buffs that are going to be only
temporary so going through that process
you're going to end up wanting to know
more and more and more what you're going
to end up doing
where you're going to end up going with
it now i play
like i said i played for a little bit of
time and i
checked out the way that they end up
doing the underworld
well i'm getting ahead of myself there's
so many different things you can do with
this game
so i'm just gonna briefly talk about
um weapons uh you're gonna have the
access to multiple different weapons
uh each of them have very unique
abilities you got a shield a bow a spear
and then your sword those are the only
ones i was
able to unlock i don't know if there's
any more than that but those are the
ones that i saw
when i started it looked like there was
a pedestal area for two more so
i wonder if those two more are going to
be there also
now uh throughout that time you're gonna
end up finding
more people throughout the whole entire
game so you're gonna find
more of your um more of your gods that
are gonna help give you buffs
over time now you're going to be able to
get yourself stronger by using these
certain types of
like oils or gems or whichever you want
to call it to be able to place into your
mirror which is going to permanently
buff you
and then you're going to have other
abilities like increasing your
your home area so you have these
cosmetics that you can end up changing
in addition to being able to give you
little buffs uh from certain areas
so there's a lot of little aspects of
the game that make it vastly
more in-depth than you think it would be
so throughout the whole entire time
you're going okay well what's going to
be a better decision
do i need a key for this do i need to be
able to do this
it takes time over time you're just
going to have to keep playing and
playing and playing
now when it comes to
the long-term effects of this game
like i said i was hooked like i wanted
to keep playing
and i had to end up getting off because
of family stuff going on but
i was like i'm going to keep playing i
want to keep playing one more time one
more time one more time
and the one time that i felt like that
was the case was when i was playing
like a like a call of duty or if i was
playing some type of game like that
where i was just like oh one more match
one more time
let's just go one more time and this
gave me those same feelings
of wanting to keep going more and more
and more because i want to see how much
better
i can get and how much better the
game can get and i just wanted to keep
going and going going now
the animation of it uh it very much is
very
smooth uh very much uh
quick for fighting uh i really like the
animation
the cosmetics everything that they ended
up doing with
that aspect of the game now i thought it
had
that really really cool pop-up uh where
you're going into
your conversation you got a pop-up of
who you're talking
to and you have full voice over which
was really really nice
now i really recommend that you guys go
out pick up hades
give it a try get instantly hooked and
you're gonna you're gonna absolutely
love it
i don't i don't know why you wouldn't
want to just continue to play it's
fantastic
so all right so everybody thank you very
much for taking this iron lords podcast
first look at hades
now if you guys are looking to check out
the ireland's podcast check us out on
sundays and remember check out our
lawyers of gaming.net which is where
you're going to find all your gaming
needs and everything you're going to
find is right there
we have our reviews we have our
knowledge of games that are coming out
we have everything going on that you can
think of it's fantastic
so thank you all very much and have a
fantastic day
bye everybody just
hold ex uh hold the tack two striker
revelation represent
times per head you're your attack deals
bonus damage equal to five percent
of your current
gold your attack fires a wave that
you're supposed to the damage
that'll do oh
each time the built to ensure no one
gets out
we'll see about that
it's really interesting because every
time you do this it always looks
different
close the gap
right now
come with my blade
there's only one heavenly archer i know
of well several really
anyway
the power of the hunt helps keep me
company so maybe it'll help you
did you get the vid results no
not till monday we won't know it's a
monday
it deals more damage your
special is stronger
but more than likely
we'll see how this
who goes love this stuff
that's additional hp
that looks like food which means health
so we're gonna go with hp overall hp
ooh money
overall hp incident provides
one time benefit when acquired
should give me points
i ate like 30 pieces of sushi today from
a sushi buffet so much regret
there's never any regret
from too much sushi
i would eat more than that and be okay
i normally get three rolls three rolls
guys three girls
three rolls of sushi okay that's three
six so three times six is 21 right there
and then i'll get two or three regular
little sushi pieces
and i'm in heaven and i can still eat
more
there's never any regret
come
oh yeah oh it's on like donkey kong
right now my friends
gotta step it up
dude i can't wait for shadow lines to
come out i'm so ready for it
i couldn't see that
oh
oh
that was not a good round
i don't know what this is i'm going this
way this is gonna be a harder boss room
but we know what the boss is and that's
gonna be easy so
you and me
boom one there else be a mess let's see
here
hi there in the name of hades olympus i
accept this message
why hello hello there little godlings i
have to say you're
quite the specimen and so i've decided i
shall aid you for the moment
you interested
epic after you take damage your foes
around you
of the effect of weak
that's nice and the power to break
hearts oh
[Music]
my god betty thank you so much
for the six months to your sub thank you
very much betty greatly appreciate you
lots of love thanks once again so
remember guys
i appreciate you guys for resubbing and
being around right now
because i know that it's gonna be
very very difficult because warcraft is
kind of meh i am the alpha sub
well i appreciate you for coming and
being in that office up
i appreciate you coming and hanging out
remember now is the time that you guys
should be stacking
points right you stack travel points now
so when we get to doing mythic plus
carries again you can just be asking for
carries
and on top of that we're gonna be
changing point values for runs and stuff
like that
so it's gonna be awesome for you guys
you got like 33 what 33 runs what are
you just sitting the channel all day
oh like i'm expecting a lot of you guys
who are regulars
who don't normally use channel points oh
no
welcome
oh no no
you